und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend das wird nun das letzte
heute-journal bevor morgen weihnachten
losgeht festliche tage und dann die halb
winter schlafende zeit zwischen den
jahren von der man jedesmal erwartet
dass man endlich zur ruhe kommt wenn die
welt einen lässt und das tut sie ja
manchmal nicht es liegt in der natur
dieser tage dass man sich auch sie
freuen soll jauchzet frohlocket
verlangt bachs oratorium das müsste es
nicht man spürt den druck auch so
verlangt freude sozusagen von sich
selbst für menschen die in diesem jahr
den mittelpunkt ihres lebens verloren
haben ist das eine schier unerträgliche
belastung
wir beginnen die sendung mit einem
bericht von dominik müller russ l aus
einem der juli flutgebiete der mehr ist
dieser bericht als nur das er ist unsere
verbeugung vor allem den festliche
freude nicht wirklich gelingen kann
nicht dieses jahr
wir sind erschöpft
wir sind müde es sind keine fröhlichen
es sind keine frohen tage ins bis teil
in der voreifel monate der plackerei
liegen hinter ihnen und während es sich
andernorts die welt nun festlich und
schön macht wird den menschen in den
flutgebieten ganz besonders bewusst dass
sie hier zu hause ihre heimat verloren
haben
schmerzt weil das zu hause gab an
weihnachten ja so wichtig ist ein
sicheren ort zu haben wo ich geborgen
bin ich geschützt bin mit meiner familie
zusammen sein kann das fehlt den
menschen jetzt und es ist ein großes
gefühl von unsicherheit
kein weihnachten wie immer nicht
fröhlich nicht froh sondern schmerzlich
wird es auch bei heike schmidt ihre
tochter kann heiligabend nicht bei ihnen
seien wegen angstzuständen und
panikattacken musste sie kürzlich in
eine klinik es war und ist
alles zu viel
die drähte hat als wenn es weg mit spürt
regeln der nicht da ist und wo kommt an
den karstadt durch auch diese
panikattacken ist kein schönes
weihnachten für uns es ist auch keine
weihnachtsstimmung dann doch es gibt
auch immer wieder trost und hilfe im
großen im kleinen mit der geschenke
aktion etwa bei der betroffene sich
etwas wünschen dürfen und andere diese
wünsche erfüllen weihnachtsdeko und neue
inline skates für die kinder von
familien gute geschenkt von fremden
große dankbarkeit für jede anteilnahme
man zusammenstehen man hat sich nochmal
besser kennengelernt
das zusammenrücken hilft mal mehr mal
weniger
handballschuhe und eine friteuse bekommt
familie schmitz bei der geschenke aktion
und für die tochter in der klinik einen
gutschein doch eigentlich wünscht sich
heike schmidt
nun mal wieder hat die jetzt unsere
tochter anna dass das wieder vorbeigeht
das
wünschen
nicht nur autos und häuser sondern auch
lebens gewissheiten und ein
grundvertrauen in die welt sind in
swisttal kaputt gegangen doch vielleicht
ist weihnachten gerade deshalb auch so
passend und wichtig wie nie zuvor mit
seiner botschaft
gott lässt seine welt und seine menschen
nicht allein und ich glaube in vielen
gemeinden ist gerade wichtig die
botschaft des engels aus der
weihnachtsgeschichte der sagt fürchtet
euch nicht und das ist auch das was wir
hier bei uns in der gemeinde mit karten
aus teilen dieses fürchtet euch nicht
also wir stellen der furcht etwas
entgegen morgen abend wird es in der
kirche ein großes weihnachtsessen geben
für alle die kein wohnzimmer mehr haben
pfarrerin müller glück glaubt es wird
schön und sehr traurig werden
ingo pennings ist bürgermeister von
schleiden einer stadt in der eifel in
nordrhein-westfalen guten abend herr
bürgermeister
einen wunderschönen guten abend wie
kommen die menschen in ihrer stadt mit
diesem weihnachtsfest nach der
katastrophe zurück
ja es ist für uns alle eine ganz
besondere situation war natürlich nichts
normales in diesem jahr die korona
pandemie könnten wir ja alles schon
jetzt ist dieses jahr die
hochwasserkatastrophe noch dazugekommen
die einfach dazu führt dass viele
menschen nicht in ihren eigenen häusern
wohnen können in ferienwohnungen
untergebracht sind bei familien oder
eben in der mietwohnung und nicht das
übliche fest zu hause verbringen können
das geht schon sehr stark an die psyche
und dazu kommen eben die erinnerung an
die schrecken der nacht die immer noch
in den knochen der menschen stecken wie
groß ist die zahl der menschen die
unmittelbar betroffen waren die jetzt
tatsächlich ihr zuhause oder vielleicht
sogar angehörige verloren haben
insgesamt den lehrer statt
wir haben die schreckliche zahl von
neuen menschen die ihr leben hier leider
im stadtgebiet verloren haben vom
hochwasser direkt betroffenen
kalkulieren wir mit einer zahl von 3000
haushalten das sind in etwa 5000
menschen
wie viele genau in anderen unterkünften
im moment untergebracht sind können wir
als verwaltung gar nicht sagen weil das
natürlich sich im privaten bereich
bewegt das heißt der sich an uns gewandt
hatte und um hilfe gebeten haben die
zahlen kann man natürlich dachten wir
sehr gerne geholfen aber viele hatten
sich auch sehr schnell selber
organisiert und beispielsweise sich
schon ferienwohnungen direkt am anfang
mit wo wir gar nicht unterstützen
mussten wie kann ein bürgermeister einer
solchen stadt die durch so was schlimmes
hindurch gegangen ist jetzt fünf monate
später helfen
immer noch ein großes thema ist
tatsächlich die unterbringung bei
manchmal eben die jetzige unterbringen
zeitlich befristet war und meine
alternative benötigt manchmal auch sehr
kurzfristig nicht immer hat es mit der
heizung vor dem winter geklappt da
versuchen wir zu helfen ja und darüber
hinaus in allen bereichen der beratungen
der unterstützung aber helfen können
versuchen wir dass der anbieter
tatsächlich von anfang an den leitsatz
geprägte mit uns redet den versuchen wir
auch zu helfen und das gilt auch
weiterhin ist es dann so dass sozusagen
der wunsch der kinder nach einem
normalen weihnachten auch den eltern
hilft irgendwie darüber hinwegzukommen
ja ich glaube ja also man merkt auch in
dieser katastrophe familie geteilt
familie gibt kraft ich bin auch ganz
besonders stolz darauf dass wir uns als
stadtgebiet auch wirklich als einheit
durch die ganze katastrophenlage kämpfen
ich hab leider meine amtszeit damals und
2018 im dezember gestartet mit einer
brandserie danach kam corona dh die
flutkatastrophe war jetzt eigentlich die
dritte größere katastrophe die uns aber
zusammengebracht haben und genau das ist
es tatsächlich was wir versuchen uns
gegenseitig stärke und kraft zu geben
dass sich in den familien das sehe ich
aber auch in freundeskreisen in
nachbarschaften
man sagt hier so ein bisschen wo
schatten ist da ist eben auch nicht und
das licht blüte in der dunkelheit am
herzen das merkt man daran dass menschen
die vielleicht jahren eigentlich
miteinander gesprochen haben
mittlerweile offen dazu kommen und
tatsächlich sich auch nachts schon in
der katastrophe unterstützt haben eine
muss ich sagen wirklich tolle
entwicklung in einer ganz schwierigen
phase man war der moment in der nacht wo
sie gespürt haben diese katastrophe wird
die stadt für lange zeit prägen
tja da gab es eigentlich mehrere momente
also ich habe
die nacht zu großen teil der entweder im
der koste koordinierungsstelle feuerwehr
oder in meinem eigenen katastrophen raum
im rathaus verbracht beide liegen im
rathaus körper sind von der luft den 15
meter auseinander entfernen das heißt
ich habe dann immer einfach nur die
räume gewechselt und wir hatten
natürlich unterwegs immer wieder
unterschiedliche stimmungslagen also es
gab verschiedene eskalationsstufen und
der schlimmste moment für uns war
eigentlich als wir realisieren mussten
wir können nicht mehr jedes hilfegesuch
auch tatsächlich positiv beantworten das
heißt wir wussten es sind menschen in
not die brauchen unsere hilfe die
brauchen hilfe der einsatzkräfte
wir können aber die hilfe nicht leisten
das muss ich sagen war für mich
persönlich ein ganz schlimmer moment und
die gesichter in der
koordinierungsstelle der feuerwehr haben
mir gezeigt das sehen alle so die truppe
hat sich selber verschrieben menschen zu
helfen menschen zu retten und das
konnten wir ab einem gewissen zeitpunkt
nicht mehr da war klar wie hoch die
stadt die menschen werden können sie
hoffnung haben dass weihnachten nächstes
jahr ihre gemeinde wieder zu sich
gekommen ist
tja
das ist eine sehr gute frage ich hoffe
es also ich wünsche uns ein tatsächlich
ein ruhiges jahr 2022 dass uns die
chance gibt einfach wirklich die die
normalität wieder zu erlernen wir haben
da im moment eine ganz schwierige
situation weil von den 18 ortschaften
die wir haben fünf schwer beschädigt
sind dass die gesamte anlage und
normalität und leid sind ganz
nacheinander das war auch in dieser flut
phase sehr schwierig und ich fand's
einfach überragend wie viel
unterstützung aus den anderen
ortschaften gekommen ist und ich glaube
dass diese kraft die wir da gewonnen
haben die immer noch irgendwo da ist
auch wenn es natürlich im moment
manchmal momente gibt wo ein fachmann
denkt man schafft es nicht mehr dass uns
das auch durch das nächste jahr tragen
wird und wir dann wirklich ja vielleicht
das weihnachtsfest im nächsten jahr in
deutlich normalen umständen erleben
können als das im moment der fall ist
wir wünschen ihnen das viel glück herr
bürgermeister ihnen ihrer stadt und all
den anderen gemeinden die denen es geht
wieder ihren
danke auch
wir hatten dieses gespräch gegen 20 uhr
und wir kommen um das corona thema auch
heute nicht herum obwohl die aktuellen
zahlen der neuinfektionen
noch fast so was wie beruhigend wirken
sie bewegen sich tatsächlich weiter
etwas nach unten aber das täuscht sagen
die statistiker für sie steht fest dass
sich das bald grundlegend ändern wird
sobald sich die omikron variante
hierzulande durchsetzt wie anderswo und
es spricht nun wirklich nichts dafür
dass deutschland dem entgehen kann über
den stand der erkenntnisse und maßnahmen
heute christian kirsch
deutschland und impft heute in berlin
die neue regierende bürgermeisterin bei
einer impfaktion für kinder so viele
impfungen wie möglich vor der
gefürchteten omikron welle die
hauptstadt hat hohe impfquoten leistet
sich daher eine kleine weihnachtspause
ich morgen am heiligen abend und am
ersten feiertag
wird es eine pause geben und es wird am
silvesterabend und am ersten januar eine
kurze pause geben alle anderen tage wird
durchgeimpft
gut eine million impfungen im
vorweihnachtlichen deutschland allein
gestern dazu heute erste vorsichtig
optimistische studien aus großbritannien
das renommierte imperial college findet
daten die die hoffnung begründen dass
omikron mildere erkrankungen verursacht
mindestens 20 prozent weniger
krankenhausaufenthalte bei omikron
infizierten länger als eine nacht
blieben bis zu 45 prozent weniger kranke
das entlastet die kliniken virologe
christian drosten hält das für
wegweisend omikron sei gegenüber delta
etwas abgeschwächt der unterschied bei
schweren verläufen aber weiter unklar
auch eine zweite studie aus schottland
untermauert diesen positiven befund
dennoch raten fachleute weiter zur
vorsicht
angenommen das ist ein faktor 2 melder
dann ist es natürlich so dass wenn dann
die instanz wiederum doppelt so hoch ist
wie sie bisher war das dann wieder
genauso viele personen die vorher von
der krankenhaus tür stehen viele
infizierte bedeuten eben auch viele
kranke auch in deutschland ist um ikon
klar auf dem vormarsch ist der erreger
schwächer oder sind es die impfungen die
jetzt schützen
wahrscheinlicher ist es dass eben
menschen die geimpft sind oder genesen
sind omikron besser beherrschen das
heißt in der konsequenz natürlich
menschen die nicht geimpft sind haben
nach wie vor auch mit omikron ein risiko
schwer zu erkranken möglicherweise daran
zu versterben also nach natürlich auch
hier gilt als die impfungen ist das was
er es auch gegen monique ohne
impfung hilft und auf tabletten das
medikament axel vieth wurde jetzt im
eilverfahren in den usa zugelassen bei
risikopatienten soll es die gefahr einer
krankenhauseinweisung oder gar des todes
um 88 prozent reduzieren können
man sollte vor allem verhindern krank zu
werden aber nun ließe sich ein schwerer
verlauf auch abwehren durch diese
tablette
schatten und licht also vor der fünften
welle heute meldete das rk ii den ersten
omikron toten in deutschland
und gundula führt das thema weiter mehr
in den usa ist die omikron variante
mittlerweile dominant die
bundesregierung hat sie deshalb ab
samstag als hoch risikogebiet eingestuft
ebenso wie spanien und portugal
wer aus einem dieser hoch risikogebiete
nach deutschland einreist und nicht
vollständig geimpft oder genesen ist
muss für zehn tage in quarantäne davon
befreien kann man sich frühestens nach
fünf tagen mit einem negativen test das
gilt nun nicht mehr für österreich das
von der risikoliste gestrichen wird
die bundesregierung will die evakuierung
von besonders schutzbedürftigen menschen
aus afghanistan beschleunigen dafür
sollen bürokratische hürden bei der
visa-vergabe abgebaut werden sagte
außenministerin berbalk bei der
vorstellung eines aktionsplanes für
afghanistan noch seien 15.000 menschen
in afghanistan
deren aufnahme deutschland zugesagt habe
darunter 135 deutsche staatsangehörige
seit der machtübernahme der taliban habe
die bundesregierung rund 10.000 menschen
in sicherheit gebracht
in hongkong ist ein symbol der
demokratiebewegung entfernt worden der
letzte ort öffentlichen gedenkens an das
tiananmen massaker
1989 in peking die säule der schande
wurde abgebaut mit der skulptur auf dem
universitätsgelände war der vielen
todesopfer unter den
demokratie-aktivisten gedacht worden
seit inkrafttreten des umstrittenen
sicherheitsgesetze der chinesischen
führung gehen die behörden in hongkong
hart gegen die demokratiebewegung vor
der designierte cdu vorsitzende
friedrich merz unterstützt den wunsch
der ukraine nachlieferung von
defensivwaffen der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung sagte er
angesichts des massiven truppenaufmarsch
es der russischen armee an der
ukrainische ostgrenze seien die bitten
um solche waffen ohne zweifel legitim
hier bilder von übungen des ukrainischen
militärs mit us raketen die ukraine
hatte unter anderem um flugabwehrkanonen
und ältere fregatten gebeten
tja was plant putin mit der ukraine das
ist die frage die verantwortliche schon
länger und auch über weihnachten sehr
unruhig schlafen lässt was russlands
streitkräfte seien
an der grenze zusammenziehen soldaten
panzer waffen und logistik das ist alles
deutlich mehr als man für ein bloßes
säbelrasseln braucht niemand weiß was
putins ware pläne sind wenn das aber ein
waffengang werden sollte dann stünde das
dafür notwendige an den entscheidenden
stellen mittlerweile bereit putin selbst
beschreibt freilich seine haltung als
verteidigung er verlange nur ein ende
der bedrohung russlands durch die nato
bedrohlich ist für putin dass die nato
der ukraine nicht verbietet um aufnahme
in das westliche bündnis zu werben
jedenfalls für den westen war die
ukraine das wichtigste thema von putins
jährlicher pressekonferenz heute
christiansen war für uns dort in der
ukraine krise wird im kreml einer
vernebelungstaktik vorgeworfen diese
schleusen bei der pressekonferenz heute
aber sollen dem kampf gegen korona
dienen alles nur zur desinfektion so
auch die leise hoffnung der durch
nebelten presse drei pcr tests musste
man vorlegen dann durfte man rein so
streng ist russland sonst nie wenn es um
corona geht aber heute spricht ja der
präsident einmal im jahr bereitet putin
sich selbst diese bühne und der kreml
führt regie eines der zentralen themen
heute natürlich die ukraine und putin
wiederholt
wir haben klar und deutlich gemacht dass
eine weitere nato erweiterung richtung
osten inakzeptabel ist was gibt es daran
nichts zu verstehen haben wir etwa
raketen an der grenze der usa
stationiert nein es sind die usa die mit
ihren raketen zu uns gekommen sind sie
stehen bereits vor unserer haustür
putin will sicherheitsgarantien die er
so nicht bekommen wird weder von der
nato noch von den usa und lässt das
russische militär an der grenze zur
ukraine aufmarschieren und er zeichnet
ein bild von einem bedrohten russland
sie haben uns in den 90ern gesagt kein
zentimeter richtung osten und was ist
passiert wir wurden betrogen wir wurden
dreist betrogen es gab fünf wählen der
nato-erweiterung und dann tauchen diese
raketenabwehrsystem in polen und
rumänien auf
rumänisch
putin betont zwar immer wieder dass
russland keinen krieg wolle aber
garantien will er heute auch nicht
aussprechen und so bleibt einer der
meist gestellten fragen dieser tage wird
russland in der ukraine einen krieg
anzetteln
ich habe den eindruck dass diese truppen
konzentration andere ziele verfolgt es
ging darum einen unmittelbaren kontakt
mit dem präsidenten der usa herzustellen
ich neige zu vorsichtigem optimismus
ich denke eine direkte militärische
konfrontation ist ausgeschlossen und
russland ist weder bereit noch willens
zu einem heißen krieg
in der halle versucht mehr als 500
journalistinnen und journalisten mit
schildern um die aufmerksamkeit des
präsidenten zu buhlen die fragen mussten
vorher genau ausformuliert eingereicht
werden es ging auch um lokale themen um
die wirtschaft die hohen gaspreise und
putin lobte sein land dann noch für das
corona krisen-management das seit wochen
in russland jeden tag mehr als 1000
menschen wegen corona sterben spricht
ende stand putins botschaft egal ob
virus oder die nato russland bringt
keiner zufall der ausgewählten presse
heute in moskau hat es offenbar gefallen
applaus nach mehr als vier stunden putin
pressekonferenz
und wir haben noch nachrichten aus der
wirtschaft bevor wir dann abheben in die
weiten des wetters am tag vor
weihnachten suchten viele noch in
letzter minute nach geschenken das aber
wegen corona kaum in den innenstädten
der einzelhandel spricht von einem
trüben weihnachtsgeschäft valerie das
kann heute aber nur eine erste
vorläufige bilanz seien stimmt aber die
sieht schon ziemlich düster aus viele
sind einfach unzufrieden mit dem umsatz
das ist besonders bitter da im
vergangenen jahr ein locker und in der
vorweihnachtszeit schon das geschäft
verhagelt hat ein geschäft das eine
besondere bedeutung hat für den handel
rund 20 prozent des jahresumsatzes wird
in der zeit gemacht das einkaufen ist
beschwerlich geworden masken pflicht und
2g regeln drücken auf die einkaufslaune
durch die einlasskontrollen bilden sich
immer wieder schlangen vor den
geschäften auch lieferengpässe sind ein
problem manche ware hat es schlicht
nicht mehr in die läden geschafft vor
weihnachten wir haben deutlich über 40
prozent weniger frequenzen in den
innenstädten die umsätze liegen auch
zwischen 30 40 teilweise 50 prozent
hinter den ergebnissen von 2009 10 wir
gehen alleine davon aus dass in den
betroffenen unternehmen insgesamt über 5
milliarden euro umsatz fehlen gegenüber
2009 10 stattdessen boomt der
onlinehandel ein trend der sich schon
vor corona abgezeichnet und dieses jahr
noch mal verstärkt hat viele schenken
geld oder gutscheine das hat auch sein
gutes dadurch so hofft der einzelhandel
ist das weihnachtsgeschäft auch nach den
feiertagen noch nicht ganz rum eine
zweite bescherung an heiligabend der
einzelhandel könnte es vermutlich gut
gebrauchen vielen dank valerie nach
frankfurt
die lufthansa muss wieder tausende
flugverbindungen streichen wegen der
sich erneut zuspitzende pandemie würden
die buchungen ab mitte januar wieder
einbrechen der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung sagte lufthansa-chef
spur im winterflugplan müssten 33.000
flüge oder rund 10% abgesagt werden
außerdem streicht der konzern über
weihnachten wegen zahlreicher krank
meldungen von piloten ein dutzend
fernflüge
china hat die reisebeschränkungen wegen
corona erneut verschärft und nun sechs
wochen vor den olympischen winterspielen
in peking die stadt young mit 13
millionen einwohnern wegen dutzender
infektionsfälle in den lockdown
geschickt um die ausbreitung des virus
zu verhindern
mit ungewöhnlicher offenheit teilte das
olympische organisationskomitee in
peking mit das auch für die winterspiele
ein hohes risiko bestehe mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit werde es positive
fälle geben olympia teilnehmern seien
dritt impfungen dringend empfohlen
übermorgen soll der nachfolger des
glorreichen
hubble-weltraumteleskops ins all starten
das james webb weltraumteleskop wird
mehr sehen als jedes andere zuvor es ist
viel größer und leistungsfähiger als
hubble und dabei ist auch das
lichtspektrum entscheidend dass webb
teleskop kann ein großteil des
infraroten spektrums erkennen das sind
breitere wellenlängen die zum beispiel
nebel wie diesen durchdringen auf
solchen bildern können wir bislang
unbekannte sternen planeten und fernste
galaxien dahinter entdecken und
analysieren licht ist zwar schnell nicht
geschwindigkeit ist die höchste
physikalisch mögliche geschwindigkeit
überhaupt und trotzdem braucht licht
zeit für den langen weg zu uns je länger
es unterwegs ist desto älter ist das
bild das wir sehen und je weiter das
webb teleskop blickt desto tiefer blickt
es in die vergangenheit bis zur
entstehung erster galaxien vor mehr als
13 milliarden jahren inken klinge
berichtet
plaque und schmal zusammengefaltet
streckt sich das teleskop james webb in
die halle s 5 auf dem weltraumbahnhof in
kourou benannt nach einem ehemaligen
nasa direktor nur so passte es in die
rakete 25 jahre entwicklung und bauzeit
stecken darin eine zusammenarbeit von
nasa esa und der kanadischen
weltraumorganisation die erwartungen
sind dementsprechend hoch denn james
webb soll vielmehr sehen können als
jedes andere weltraum teleskop zuvor
wir werden etwas 9 finden das ist auch
nicht nur ein rein ein teleskop des eine
entdeckungsmaschine wir können in der
nähe von den big bang nach dem urknall
unseres universums und deswegen können
wir die ersten licht von sternen und
galaxien befinden rund 13 einhalb
milliarden jahre soll james webb
zurückblicken können und so erkenntnisse
über die entstehung unserer planeten
liefern auch spuren von leben im
universum könnte das empfindliche
teleskop entdecken wir dürfen es nur
durch die scheibe angucken jedes
staubkorn ist eine gefahr james webb
wird wenn alles klappt 1,5 millionen
kilometer entfernt im all seiner arbeit
aufnehmen reparieren geht also nicht
eine besondere herausforderung ist dass
sich der tennis platz große sonnenschutz
richtig entfaltet wie hier im test der
ist wichtig damit die instrumente an
bord kalt bleiben sie arbeiten bei bis
zu minus 2 166 kraft denn james webb
wird im infrarotbereich in den weltraum
blicken also wärmestrahlung messen und
durch staub und gaswolken hindurch
gucken
es ist wie in einer dunklen nacht man
sieht keinen menschen aber durch
infrarot kann man sogar die nase sehen
und genau so können wir all die sterne
im staub erkennen
die anspannung hier auf dem
weltraumbahnhof ist gewaltig der start
wurde immer wieder verschoben die kosten
für das projekt sind über die jahre auf
rund 10 milliarden dollar angewachsen
eine rekord summe in der unbemannten
raumfahrt kourou in französisch guyana
ist ideal für den start einer rakete
durch die nähe zum äquator verschafft
ihr die erddrehung einen ordentlichen
schub doch das große und schwere james
webb teleskop ist keine alltägliche
fracht
wir haben natürlich unsere standards
aber die anforderungen und bedürfnisse
von james webb für den staat und den
transport auf der rakete sind absolut
ungewöhnlich und schwierig für uns wir
haben da seit zehn jahren daran
gearbeitet und uns ausgetauscht um
lösungen zu finden
sicher verpackt in der ariane 5 ist
james webb nun es bleiben aber jede
menge riskante momente bis das teleskop
in etwa einem halben jahr erste bilder
schickt und wenn der countdown runter
läuft hier im kontrollzentrum werden
alle hoffen und bangen dass das ausnahme
teleskop unbeschadet sein ziel im
weltraum erreicht
und von hoch im himmel runter auf die
erde und zu uns jetzt wir wünschen ihnen
von der ganzen redaktion ein schönes ein
friedliches und ein gesundes
weihnachtsfest nichts davon ist
selbstverständlich um 23.50 meldet sich
wulf schmiese mit unserem heute-journal
update und schaut da ganz kurz vor
heiligabend nachbeben bis bald frohes
fest
[Musik]
guten abend gerade noch pünktlich vor
heiligabend fällt jetzt schnee hier in
mecklenburg vorpommern und in
brandenburg und im laufe der nacht zieht
diese schnee ostwärts ab aber es fällt
auch regen und der auf den gefrorenen
boden das bedeutet die straßen und
gehwege werden zum teil spiegelglatt und
zwar hier in diesen rutscher vierten
gebieten von niederbayern bis nach
schleswig holstein im nordosten fällt
nur schnee und die temperaturen liegen
im osten und im norden bei leichtem
frost von minus 12 grad sonst bleibt die
nacht bilder bis zu fünf grad am
oberrhein und morgen ist es für die
allermeisten sehr mild mit
höchsttemperaturen von vier bis neun
grad und nur im nordosten bleibt es
deutlich kälter mit werten knapp über
null grad das ist eine richtige
luftmassengrenze und an dieser
luftmassengrenze fällt morgen auch
häufig regen schnee ist da anfänglich
gar nicht so viel dabei das sind
einzelne schneeschauer mecklenburg
vorpommern auch aus der schweiz heraus
ziehen regenwolken auf deswegen bleibt
ist auch in süddeutschland trüb mit
regen
hier fällt kaum regen vom vogler bis
etwa zur eifel im norden ist für regen
unterwegs und da kann es auch noch glatt
sein bei einem starken bis stürmischen
wind aus nördlichen richtungen am ersten
feiertag 10 schnee und regen weiter nach
süden dann kann es in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen kräftig schneien dann
bleibt es dann auch blatt im norden
dagegen strahlt die sonne bei minus fünf
grad über dem neuschnee da liegen dann
nämlich so ein bis fünf zentimeter und
die sonne die zeigt sich auch am zweiten
feiertag im nordosten noch sehr
spendabel guten abend